ambition but to free her country and her
people
and I say
and I say the labor party stands with
you and a labor government would do too
now conference it's a great honor to
make the closing speech before our
traditional anthems to close the week
just as John Prescott did back in the
day although I think I look better in a
dress
I hope we're doing proud today I love
the traditions of our movement from the
Durham miners Gala to the toll puddle
Martyrs Festival
but
conference there's one part of our
history that I will never celebrate and
that's losing elections
just think how it all feel meeting here
in this Hall in a few years time after a
term of a labor government back in power
foreign
this is the labor party so I've no doubt
that we'll also be discussing how
further we'd like to go once we've
debated the CAC report for around 20
minutes
but conference what I will say
is when the tour is deliver one percent
of what they promise
they talk endlessly about that one
percent and we never hear about the list
of broken promises
when we deliver 99 of what we promise we
talk endlessly about the one percent we
didn't instead
we set a high bar but just think about
the historic labor governments and their
legacy
they didn't please all of our movement
all of the time including me but those
labor governments made history the NHS
Social Security the welfare state
Council housing modern higher education
the open University
decriminalizing homosexuality outlawing
racial discrimination
introducing equal pay the national
minimum wage sure start the evolution
The Good Friday agreement civil
Partnerships equal pay out the human
rights out and the world's first climate
change Act
thank you
a conference if we're not proud of
ourselves don't expect anyone else to do
it for us
and just think what that future Party
Conference could have to celebrate
we've shown this week how different
we'll be
not just in our vision
but with our plan for Britain
starting with the biggest challenge
facing not just our country but the
world will tackle the climate crisis
head-on
we will protect our people and our
planet and we will pull out all the
stops to build a fairer and Greener
Britain as care set out yesterday
through our green Prosperity plan we
will unleash a green Industrial
Revolution by reaching a hundred percent
uh clean Power by 2030. we will save 93
billion pounds of energy bills and
through Great British energy
we will give British power right back to
the British people
[Applause]
a conference I said on Sunday
that moment of choice is upon us
a moment to show the country that we are
ready to govern
well conference I know I'm a bit biased
but boy do I think that we've shown that
now it isn't just that we have better
policies although we do
it isn't just that we will be more
competent
although we will
is that our values differ fundamentally
and our policies are not better despite
our values but because of them labor
values the country's values too
yet too often when it comes to elections
people feel that they have a choice of
heart versus head values our competence
I say to those watching at home
this week
we have shown it's a choice you will
never have to make again
and this past week the Tories have shown
it too
the conservative party are no longer
pretending to be competent and stable
today's Tories will plunge us into chaos
in pursuit of their Dogma divide the
country to rule it
and regards rules as for you and not for
them
[Applause]
I mean they said tough on crime
they brought crime to number 10.
Defenders of the free market the
Market's in free fall
England's green and pleasant land
fracket
from the party of stability to causing
earthquakes from the party of business
to a slap down from the IMF from the
party of serious government to the party
of parties
let's trust has even crashed the port
market now that is a disgrace
now you think net snelson the trough was
one of the things that they could manage
when interest rates were low
and borrowing was cheap
they sacrifice public services for
austerity now they're borrowing just as
interest rates are soaring to think this
was the party that claimed they were for
sale money
that's what one high-flying new Tory MP
certainly fought back in 2012
he wrote a pamphlet demanding a balanced
budget every year
he said
fiscal Prudence is the very least we
should expect from a Chancellor and if
they failed they should face a 20 pay
cut
I tell you what that Tory and pulling
must be absolutely furious with a new
Chancellor
except to use the new Tory Chancellor
and you know what I've got a funny
feeling you won't be taking that pay cut
either
because you see pay cuts are for other
people
he won't even let the budget Watchdog
tell him just how much of our money he
is handing over to the super rich
they used to say the Tories knew the
value of nothing but the cost of
everything now they don't even know that
now the next election
won't be a choice between a strong
economy or a fair Society
we don't have to choose one or the other
because you can't have one without the
other a not unequal economy is an
inefficient one
is perhaps the starkest difference
between us and the Tories never again
can we let them pretend that they are
the Patriotic Party I love my country
that's why I want so much better for it
but the Tories now think our biggest
economic problem is you the working
people of Britain
and while they think you are the
country's greatest weakness we know that
you are our greatest strength
and that's why Rachel and I will make
the minimum wage a real living wage
because we are not just the party of
higher growth but of higher wages too
now we know what the Tories think
the new prime minister and her
Chancellor said it out loud
the problem is that British workers are
idlers not grafters the irony from this
lot
let's just says she doesn't like
handouts then handed 150 billion pounds
to the energy Giants they believe in
undoubts all right
and it's the same with their other top
priority unlimited Bankers bonuses it's
the same old Tory ideology you
incentivize the richest by giving them
more money and you incentivize the rest
of us by taking it away conference it
hasn't worked before and it won't wash
now
now I know they'd rather forget it but
we're now in 12 years in Satori
government even if we are on our fourth
prime minister
and where are they now David Cameron the
privatized prime minister sold to
greensill what was his greatest
achievement fooling the lib Dems not
exactly a high bar
if you care about power for power's sake
and have no principles no policies and
no plan you end up with a pointless
Premiership remembered only as a pub
quiz answer
and then of course we had Theresa May
I remember her telling us that if you
were a citizen of the world you were a
citizen of nowhere if only we'd known
about their green cards and tax
loopholes their politicians becoming
like their donors residents of
everywhere taxpayers of nowhere
and then there's Boris Johnson
I do owe him one apology
I said he couldn't organize a booze up
in a brewery
turns out he could organize a bruise up
pretty much anywhere just a shame he
couldn't organize anything else
foreign
party with a serious plan
he had a plan for a serious party
I'll miss one thing though as inflation
ran out of control at least his jokes
were one thing that got cheaper every
week
but the real problem wasn't that his
jokes were so cheap it was that his
mistakes were so expensive he ended his
time claiming he was forced from office
by the Deep State the only deep state
that forced him from office was the one
he left our country in
foreign
I had to use all of my Boris lines now
while he still remembered and while
everyone knows who he is
before he becomes a footnote in the
failure of the history books
well conference at least that's what the
new prime minister must be hoping for
because he'll be sat on the back benches
plotting his comeback with a glint in
his eye thinking I wasn't so bad after
all was I
what a sorry State of Affairs
and what does Liz trust have to say
after a decade in government
apparently they were wrong all along
she's now asking for seven years to fix
it yet offering us even more of the
ideology that caused the problems in the
first place
she just she doesn't just think that
we're lazy she must think that we're
stupid as well
and that brings me to this new
government
openly chosen for loyalty not ability a
Ministry of all the talentless
frankly conference when I looked at the
benches opposite last week I thought the
clowns had escaped the circus not so
much Flying Circus a lying circus
now maybe I'm being unfair my new
opposite number
Her First Act was to get to grips with
the real crisis in our NHS
the spread of a new and dangerous
Contagion
not the Omicron variant
the Oxford comma
now that's a comma before the word and
in case you were wondering
something like this sentence
GPS are overwhelmed ambulances not
turning up beds are full waiting times a
rocketing the NHS is starved of
investment and it's all the fault of the
Tory decisions
foreign
so here's another sentence that Therese
coffee won't like
a labor government will double the
number of District nurses train 5 000
new health visitors create 10 000
nursing places double the number of
medical students and we will pay for it
by reversing your handouts to the
wealthiest few
foreign
policy conference
and what a contrast to the government
you've seen this week
yesterday the country saw the care that
I know and see every day announcing a
hundred percent clean Power by 2030.
driven by a British Energy company owned
by the British people for the British
people he showed the true real
leadership this country needs
and on Monday Rachel showed how labor
would govern with competence class and
care
with her as the UK's first ever female
Chancellor
setting out our national wealth fund to
give the British public a share of the
wealth that they create and a genuine
living wage that matches the cost of
living
and I just want to thank my own front
bench team Rachel Justin Imran and Flo
and Fleur for all that they have done
we have set out our five-point plan for
National procurement to tackle waste
fleas and lies and Unleash the Power of
public spending Our Fair work standard
to raise working conditions across the
economy alongside our new deal for
working people and we haven't stopped
there
our whole Shadow cabinet has shown we
have a team with a plan
70 percent
home ownership our renters Charter a
clamp down on buy to let Council Housing
Council Housing Council housing
the Hillsborough law a domestic abuse
register and a new football regulator
sewerage sanctions job center reform and
a transformational industrial strategy
insulation Innovation
inspiration all in one
thirteen thousand more police officers
to keep our communities safe
new Navy ships built by unionized
workers in British shipyards
closing the tax break for private
schools to fund education for all
preschool breakfasts for children new
bus services in public hands and as
contracts expire restoring public
ownership of the railways
conference our shuttle cabinet a show
model labor government will be radical
responsible realistic but delivering
this message
would be absolutely impossible without
all of you
our brilliant activists who campaigned
through the wind and the rain and that's
just outside this building
if you ever needed proof that an onshore
Wind Farm can deliver get outside the
Pullman
now I have too many people to thank
but I want to mention our brilliant
chair Alice Perry standing down from the
nuc
and Diana Holland who is stepping down
as party treasure after 12 years we all
owe her a debt of gratitude
we could probably do river also in in
the Chancellor's office as well
and then finally a thank you to
Liverpool for hosting our conference
now while the Tories would be a shame to
show their faith here you've shown us
the warmth and the pride that defines
this city
conference this week we have shown how
together
we will transform this country and the
depth and the talent across our whole
party
and we've come together
to honor our history as only labor can
be no doubt
the times ahead are going to be tough
but now let's rise to the moment and
deliver for working people of Britain
let's build a fairer Greener future with
a labor government in power once again
thank you
thank you
well a really warm reception there for
Labor's Deputy leader Andrew she's not
of course the chancellor that's Rachel
Reeves she has the shadow chance for the
duchy of Lancaster though but um Angela
Reyna's speech there really well
received very warmly received very
confident speech let's bring in our
Deputy political editor Sam Coates
um Sam she was always going to go down
well at the labor conference wasn't she
she talks about today's Tories pursuing
us into chaos a real living wage more
Council housing what did you think of
her speech
well it's the traditional Victory lap
speech from the deputy leader it happens
every year at this point effectively
closing the conference there are just a
few uh songs and other rituals to get
done and then everybody will depart from
here uh in Liverpool
um it went through in her own language
many of the announcements that kirstama
did yesterday it also uh roused the
crowd with a run-through of all the
things that labor achieved in office of
course that off at that period in office
quite some time ago now uh 1997 to 2010
what was it perhaps slightly odd about
it maybe for viewers at home is we're in
the middle of a financial crisis seeing
quite a jokey speech at this point in
what is turning into being a very
important serious political day perhaps
slightly jarring but in the context of
this conference where they are very
happy it's arguably been the most
successful conference I've been at for
the labor party uh certainly on its own
terms since 2006 uh so a confident labor
party happy with Kirsten's speech
avoiding many of the rounds that often
beset it uh allowing itself in that
Angela Ranger's speech so something of a
pat on the back if you want to know
Labor's reaction to the current
situation that it is Rachel Reeves the
shadow chancellor who is out and about
issuing statements um she has just said
uh of what we're seeing in the markets
the emergency intervention by the bank
of England uh and the fact that it
looked this morning as a pension fund
might end up ultimately being gummed up
because the amount of money they're
having to raise because of the
uncertainty on the markets in recent
days following uh the chancellor and Liz
truss's big great statement on Friday
Rachel Reeves saying this morning people
will be deeply worried about the impact
of this turmoil on their mortgage their
pension and their cost of living this is
a crisis made in number 10 and is the
direct result of a Tory government as
Reckless actions which include a tax cut
for the richest one percent their
decisions will cause higher inflation
and higher interest rates and are not a
credible plan for growth the chancellor
must make an urgent statement on how he
is going to fix the crisis that he has
made so that's Labor's response to what
going on Jane if I may let me just
update you where we are because things
are moving incredibly fast at the moment
so you've had the bank of England
stepping in today Wednesday to deal with
the turmoil caused by that uh statement
by crazy quantity and the grace
statement with all those tax cuts that
was announced on Friday requiring an
extra 72 billion pounds of borrowing
that plus what would appear to be
relatively careless statements by the
chancellor over the weekend sending the
market uh into some turbulence now this
morning the treasury have put out a
statement basically acknowledging the
bank of England's actions suggesting
that the consequence of international
volatility rather than admitting uh that
there's any direct line between Friday
and today as far as I can tell there
isn't any plan for any kind of great
intervention or further statement uh
from number 10 or quasi come on saying
that treasury statement just from a
spokesman where's Quezon the chancellor
where is Liz trust those are the
questions right now being asked by Tory
MPS there's nobody really going public
at the moment in large numbers but Tory
MP is extremely worried about what some
of them see as acts of self-harm by the
newly elected government in the face of
many many many warnings not least from
Liz truss's Challenger in the leadership
contest Rishi sunak who said well if you
embark on the kind of tax cutting spree
that she was talking about during the uh
during the head-to-head phase of that
contest and there's a chance that
there's a run on the pound and that the
cost of debt goes up well that's exactly
Jane what we have seen in the last three
days now the bank of England effectively
having to as it were print money to buy
up government debt to stop Pension funds
basically going bus this is a very very
big and important moment as far as I can
tell in the heart of government they see
it largely as something to do with a
Communications and stakeholder
management issue meanwhile Tory MPS are
wondering whether or not the chancellor
can stay in his job because they regard
this as uh important I think in the best
possible scenario for number 10 they
might see uh some volatility today the
emergency two-week action by the bank of
England starting today but then it
hopefully calming down that's not I have
to say the political mood elsewhere in
the conservative party with lots of
people lots of people saying we told you
this might happen and you're actually
driving up the cost of debt driving up
the cost of interest rates even
supporters of Liz truss's government
economists who support this trust's
government saying they warned of exactly
this so I think it's gonna be a very
very choppy few days for the Liz trust
Premiership as we head on Saturday to
Conservative Party Conference in
Birmingham
Sam coats thanks very much while Sam has
been talking about the treasury saying
that the government will work closely
with the bank of England after the
latter launched a major economic
intervention this morning at the bank of
England announcing it will launch this
temporary UK Government Bond buying
program as an emergency move to Stave
off material risk to UK Financial
stability
well joining me now from London is chair
of the treasury select committee Mel
strong